let's take a Starbucks where all of the
baristas or all this they're all happy
they're all chipper first of all that's
a bad Starbucks to write about you would
want to write about some other Starbucks
but the thing is of all the if you get
the note that all your characters sound
the same first of all you get a look at
the attitude the other things to look at
are things like characters vocabulary
because you don't want all of your
characters to have the same vocabulary
that you do each each character has
different words for things common words
are the main thing to look at character
says yes no right wrong all the words
that pop up again and again and you need
to find the individual way for each
character to say things so one character
might say no another character might say
nope no siree and these things are
getting character related you look at
the character go how would this
character say no and what I usually do
is I'll generate a list of yes knows
truffaut any words are gonna pop up
again again and then find the one that
is that character and go okay he's
saying it this way this also comes up
with curse words can I curse in this oh
you may possum so curse words are one of
those things I found out my favorite
curse word is because I wrote a
script and then when I was reading
through it I found out that whenever
anything goes wrong with any of my
characters they open their mouth and
comes out and so I thought that's
not possible they can't all beat me so
what I wanted to do is individualize
their curse words so I went through the
script and found different ways for them
to curse and each character had their
own distinctive curse and when I came to
one of the character's name was Carter I
just off the top of my head came up with
Kitty crap that's just kiddy crap and
when I used kitty crap I went this now
changes that character into something
even better than it was so I went back
and made him he was a surfer dude and
now I made him a southern surfer dude
which I don't think I've ever seen on
screen and so now he has sort of these
weird phrases that are like you know
down-home phrases and surfer language
all at once and so I thought that makes
us a totally individual character but
word choice is one of those things where
we each have our different vocabulary
and so that's going to come out another
thing about dialogue is that we all
speak differently there are characters
that you know
put in a word like you know every few
words you know and like I don't know
like and those things which you use a
little sparingly but nonetheless create
a different rhythm for that character if
you look at Yoda Yoda is the most messed
up sentence structure ever because he
speaks backwards but he speaks backwards
and there's you know there's memes that
are like Yoda memes that have like the
backwards you know to talk and that's
such a distinctive type of dialogue if
you can come up with dialogue like that
there will be people that will write
that stuff and you'll know it's Yoda
right away and that's what you want to
do is basically come up with dialogue
that has a sentence structure kind of a
thing use of like pet words like like or
you know or whatever a different
vocabulary for common words and also
different vocabulary maybe education has
has differences one of the things I love
about Elmore Leonard novels is he takes
guys who've done a lot of time in prison
and they read in prison so they have
vocabularies that are much better than
any of the cops because they've had a
lot of time to do some reading so he has
these these characters who have just
like amazing vocabularies who are crooks
which makes them interesting characters
but it makes sense because you know a
lot of prison time to read so again
their vocabularies are better than the
cops the thing that I love about when
you're reading a Elmore Leonard novel is
when he goes to a character the
description part is written in that
characters voice so he just jumps into
that character and you're already seeing
the world through that character's eyes
before we get to them speaking and it
already is in their voice I don't know
what that has to do with anything but
it's cool
you